OARD MEETINGVLED INTSE
CO CONTEUS
VOTED TO
APPRA TEMPORY RD
FOR ELEN SLS
NTS WEG MASKS
FT>> TAKE F!
>> MASKS!NO MORE RE ALL CHILD
EVERYBODY'S TAKING, BUDDY.
>> BACASK
NO MORE MASKS. HATU LIKET?YONOO.
YS SIDE. LM.  MASKS!
>> NO,HEY'REOTSIDE.
>> THE P
OWOURE!
>> WE CAN FIND Y
WHO ARE.
>> IHIM OUT.
LEHIM OUT. BH OUBETTER O
P IT
>> EVEDYK UP.
>> I'MAC>> PEACE.
HERE. GOT A PREVI MONAG HARAEDNG
OVERE ANCOULD YOING ASE
WATCHINGHA YH  TIME TCH , I'M D
ED MS SOON AS I I CALL F THEST .
IDEW BAIT
UNTIL  A
ARWIE AY.
AMCOUNTY, MEOURS
IT WAS NOTHI LTHAT.
>> WELL, T TENSIDE
WANTO COMPL
PRR TO MEETINGWE WERE IR.ET THE
I BUMPEDLENTMADEIDE TH
F CONTROL.
A MOB MENTALITY.
LKING. BACK.
OS OF ONO WALK AND A BCHPELEWALM
INTI I SAW T CHAIRHEN
AMMAARS ERAL DOC  MAIN
SEATED ARO TBY ONE.I NOTICED SHN
AT:30,TON SOWRONR THE OWD
T
OR.
HED E OFFIIDANAN ECA
E
DOOR.
I SAID THANKTHEYD MY TMY Y VEHI.
E  A
POSITION B E VEHICLE.
THEY WERE NOID
YTI  GET OF
O  GO HO Y
WASE T FOCHPECTALPROFESSION
CHILDREN UF
E CASEN YOURS TW ISCE INIAMSON
YEAR.
WE KNOW THAT MASKS AREDAEMENTAR.
CONCERN NOW R YOUR
>>ETE
THE SIXTH GRADE  MY HO.LT TTLEHI
WE'ROHY CONCERNED  VO.TE MATED T
NOTPRESENT.AVINDOR.T  DID PS.XT
THEY'RE TWMONTHS AWAFRY GOHEIR N
>>O I UNDERSTAND THAR D COR
REMARKS YOIDT
ASKED PTSO MA ADECISIONN R WIT
GUIDANCE.
DO YOU FL  SCHOOL
YOKNF WA THEINGET
ION. BE CLEAR ABOUT THAT
I DON'T  WHE
WEACK INVEOR SAID E
PERMTE YOU
EITHER H T O
OPT FOR ONLINWHICH
ILNOFILIATED E OLS,YES,VELY A
HETHE SCT RING T
THEY HAD MASKS IO OTHEYEMITIGAT
S SUPERINTENDENT IT THE
STENVIROT  UPON TT.EN DESERVE T
GRN.
THA THAT WOULGREE THA
T  BR CHILD AND THAT'S ALL WANTH
CAE